gmail
je n'essaie cette chanson de claude
françois
ouais je regarde plus canal moi j'ai
rendu mon abonnement vous connaissez
c'est si les gars n 79 qui vous lui chez
beau temps non non c'est si le vous avez
commencé aux acolytes effectivement pour
cette météo de canal plus et vous avez
vous ai commencé par un gros coup de bol
oui vous vous promenez dans les couloirs
du martinez vous tombez vous tombez sur
alain de greef le patron des programmes
de canal + et il vous propose de
présenter la météo si c'est vrai mais si
c'est non ça commençait un tout petit
peu at on en fait moi j'étais dans
j'étais mannequin et ils ont fait un
casting dans différentes agences pour
trouver une jeune fille pour faire
simple et clara sur internet c'est
l'histoire d'une jeune comédienne à
cannes comme un roman photo sur internet
en fait j'avais comment quand vous étiez
dans le couloir un calme
tout ça pour nos amis qui cherchent du
boulot hein j'étais habillé non non
c'est fx était non c'était pas normal
allumeuse du tout mais vous dites quand
même j'ai conscience que mon physique a
beaucoup influencé son choix n'était pas
pour mes talents mes talents de
météorologues 1 m 72 52 kg travaux 85 58
89 qui cultivent ma réputation de match
et si c'est pour les chiennes de garde
c'est bien ça 85 58 89
oui j'suis pas je m'en rends pas compte
moi moi ça me va j'aurais bien aimé
faire un 90c la poitrine ces derniers
chiffres soit pas trop comment vous 85
85 cents
c'est l'année
à 5-3 dimanche
85 c'est la poitrine mais vous dites
d'ailleurs si celle ci est beaucoup de
cécile dit avec beaucoup de franchise
j'ai des petits seins mais c'est ce que
je préfère chez moi ah non non non non
je suis passé par an je suis bien avec
n'ont jamais daigné commenter l'affairé
non c'est pour ça que mon but est comme
ça ah non je connais très bien droite
sur le souss et qu' il ya des accoudoirs
je m'en sers en fait vous êtes vous dit
j'ai pas une bombe sexuelle je suis môme
sexuelle que parent 3000 vous disais à
l'époque de la météo après vous mettiez
votre gilles vos baskets et pour donner
à ce qu'ils disent est ce que vous
considérez comme une bombe sexuelle
parce que les gens applaudissaient mon
épouse adorée dans m'attendais à cannes
c'était délire à part bouton quand il
arrivait avec ta caverne et des capteurs
sur la croisette et j'ai mis autant
d'émeutes que pour vous non c'est vrai
maintenant les gens mais bien cinq fois
la cua plus non j'ai la plus de succès
qu'une fille cavell à la palme d'or
il ya eu aussi des loyers beaucoup si à
la télé quoi donc ils les gens me
connaissaient me voyez tous les jours
quoi donc bon c'est vrai qu'ils
s'habituent à vous et qui vous aime bien
mais j'avais souffert les tapis note de
service non enfin c'est dire que la
dentelle émission tu partirais rejouer
ou non mais si oui c'est pas assez
féministe pour voir ça d'un mauvais oeil
c'est comment rôle elle dit vous n'avez
pas le complexe de la petits chevaux non
parce que je me suis jamais preuve pour
moi parce les gens me parlaient souvent
de sa vie disait ce que ça me gêne pas
d'être potiche où ça moi je me suis
jamais sentie potiche
parce que on m'a pris pour faire la
météo parce que j'étais jolie et j'en
étais consciente à la base donc
effectivement
vous oubliez pas quoi enfin je me suis
jamais vraiment posé de questions par
rapport à ça ça m'a jamais gêné et les
gens avec qui je travaillais me
considérais pas comme une potiche non
maintenant il ya toujours des mauvaises
langues qui vous voient comme une
potiche et puis d'autres qui vous trouve
qu'ils sont ravis de vous voir arriver
pour la météo et qui se contente de vous
voir avec une nouvelle fera un jour
quand même c'était vous avez un peu
gueulé quand même vous avez fait une
entrée de chance de les minijupes et le
cadre à es-sénia un peu mais c'est comme
ça je suis repassé beaucoup d'heures non
mais c'était j'ai vu après on n'a rien
vu mais j'ai été le voir juste après
puisque pour ça suffit comme moi oui je
lui dis non car autrement je vais plus
me j'ai pour nature m'ont tapé la caméra
quand j'entre et c'est vrai qu'à des
daims et 1 1 qui vous a proposé un
million de francs ah oui un type non il
m'a envoyé un million francs si c'est
pas beau temps qui peut alors vous qui
l'avez vous hésitez très excusez moi à
pied c'est vrai il s'est dit cependant à
se faire beau temps on répare donc non
non c'est un petit peu voyez un enfant
est question villa calme c'est plus le
monde
un mec a proposé à cécile siméone un
million de francs pour rien du tout même
envoyé un million de francs et je
l'avais mis au point de sacrifier même
si les a pas que c'est non mais là mon
invité pas moins solvables je sais
maintenant qu'il est français
je vais pas citer de noms parce que je
veux pas me lancer l'emblavement bon
c'est s'il ya juste un petit problème
quoi moi parce que là quand on vous voit
tout ce que vous nous dites tout ça pas
de complexe de la petit ça pas mignonne
tout et pillé un petit problème est un
peu un peu fainéante
ah oui oui je suis vérité c'est vrai
reconnaît tout de suite un italien
didier j'ai toujours reconnu et moi ça
me gêne oui j'ai toujours été fait n'est
pas très bon à l'école nom vous dit j'ai
manqué deux coups de pied au cul ouais
j'ai des parents qui a été trop gentil
enfin j'étais tranquille avec moi oui
alors j'ai quitté lyon vous étiez si
vous êtes de petit pavillon donc il y en
qui je suis bien c'est terrien doté de
niro moi aussi je suis l'ayant voilà on
a tous les twittos nous allions nous
devions ouais on s'en sort bien
bonjour vous étiez dessinatrice à lyon
et vous avez quitté lyon sur un coup de
tête
oui vous avez quitté quand même sur un
coup de tête aussi non j'ai pas quitter
canal sur un coup de tête en fait
pendant mes trois ans un canal j'ai eu
quelques expériences non un an plus tard
quelques expériences donc j'ai fait un
premièrement la première année à un
cinéma théâtre avec marc hollogne mars
et je savais pas que j'étais je pouvais
jouer je me remet a demandé j'ai essayé
ça s'est bien passé
ça m'a beaucoup plu après j'ai fait un
moyen métrage est un court métrage et
j'ai beaucoup aimé le fait de jouer et
je me suis dit je vais le temps tu es là
donc pour moi j'ai pas été conseillée
mais dans ma tête je me disais que la
télé le cinéma n'était pas compatible
j'ai choisi s'il est mal et j'ai choisi
le cinéma moi j'ai choisi j'ai choisi
d'arrêter la télé et de voir ce qui
allait se passer
en fait vous n'êtes pas mariée vous
n'êtes pas quitter je vais pas quitter
canal pour vous marier c'est pas du tout
ça non
vision peut faire les deux oui oui non
mariée avec dominique casa grande
famille seulement le temps s'est pas
trop bien le fossé gardien de but du psg
c'est le deuxième vers damas d'ailleurs
barthez 320 la main pardon s'en va vers
manama
apparemment oui on va monter d'un cran
dominique oui c'est ce qu'on lui a dit
oui y'en a qui arrêtent pas te mettre le
cul alors lui il est normal ou sur
l'épaule de croiser la famille et
gibbons responsabilité on se ressemble
avec dominique casagrande on se
ressemble et c'est bien de près que
c'est bien de se ressembler avec son
accent jules avant la courte vie ma rage
une expérience avec quelques personnes
avec qui j'ai vécu effectivement d'être
opposés non ça marche pas bon moi non
enfin je trouve que non non se
ressembler en vie des mêmes choses on
est bien quoi vous êtes heureuse avec
lui là c'est mort ce soir là on se dit
pas l'a1 entre mes chers amis qui parler
non je ne vous quitteriez pas dominique
casa grande sur un coup de tête sans bon
temps sur un coup de tête avec 4 à
grands frais